las inspecciones del traslado de bienes
entre gran bretaña e irlanda del norte
forman parte de un acuerdo posterior al
break sheet cuyo objetivo es garantizar
la libre circulación a través de la
frontera irlandesa pero el partido
democrático unionista pro británico
sigue oponiéndose a los controles el
ministro de agricultura de irlanda del
norte y miembro del dup edwin poots
aseguró que finalizarán no he dado
instrucciones formales a mi secretario
permanente para que detenga todos los
controles que no estaban en marcha el 31
de diciembre de 2020 a partir de la
medianoche de hoy prepararé un documento
para la consideración del ejecutivo en
un futuro próximo para buscar un acuerdo
sobre el camino a seguir hasta que la
vice primera ministra michele o neill
del partido nacionalista irlandés sinn
fein que respalda el acuerdo calificó la
medida del dup de maniobra desde la
república de irlanda el ministro de
asuntos exteriores simon coveney sostuvo
que es una violación del derecho
internacional pero los unionistas
afirman que el protocolo de irlanda del
norte crea una frontera dura entre el
territorio y gran bretaña con elecciones
previstas para mayo en irlanda del norte
las encuestas sugieren que el sinn fein
podría convertirse en el partido más
votado por primera vez tras meses de
conversaciones la unión europea y reino
unido- no han logrado llegar a un
acuerdo para cambiar el protocolo